it's time for roses and Rose a I'm
wearing red the finale a hefty poor
goodbye Robbie
hello drunk it wasn't invited to the
live special but I'm making my own it
was the season finale of The
Bachelorette Monday night guys and
what's a finale it was Jojo war Badgley
Mischka I'm wearing forever 21 forever
21 is not a sponsor of this video but
I'd welcome it all right so on the
season finale we reiterated once again
that Jojo has trust issues
Jojo has trust issue in men okay cheers
to you Ben Higgins you gave us a whole
season of content Jordan and Ravi were
the final two guys they met JoJo's
family and Jonah's family told her that
Ravi was the safe bet because Jojo has
trust issues trust issue with men so we
see the final dates and Robby the safe
bet describes the most boring possible
future I could ever ever match it I see
her sitting on just the most comfortable
living room sofa and there was smell
food burning we overcook the meat but
we're fine with it
the
stopping young black white wine that
meatloaf and Sauvignon Blanc meatloaf
and Sauvignon Blanc don't Sully the good
name of something donk
I don't remember how to say the wine for
this point then once again we had Jojo
relive her issues of having trust issues
with Jordan and trust issue with men
she's not really sure if he's in it all
the way and she's really questioning his
love and she just says no where it's
gonna go from here like what's the
future like and I don't know Robbie
knows the future it's 4:11 and cuts in
the end because they went through this
crap every single episode this season
and they work it out every time and it's
fine
oh my god Robbie is about to propose to
Jojo my heart yearns for you and Jojo
stops Robbie from blue bows
I mean a lot of moments she said she
could not let him get down on one knee
because but for some reason my heart is
somewhere else yeah it was pretty vague
reasoning cheers to vaguely you know you
can just say no and then came the part
that kind of cemented for me but Robbie
right just night
Robbie just night being this to be
famous because Robbie was trying to cry
he literally turned his face away from
the camera so that maybe we would think
he was crying and then in the limo he
just he got a dinner napkin from
somewhere and he's just dabbing
non-existent tears just dabbing
and remember this is a live event so cut
back to the studio audience for awkward
silence cheers to awkward silence very
effective see how effective that was and
now because this is the fabulous
emotional rollercoaster that is the
bachelorettes we're happy again the only
thing that's getting me through this
moment
of Jordan by Ravi bayi we're moving on
Jordans coming Jordan comes down the
beach and he almost Trevor look up here
and then Jojo tells him that she loves
him I love you so much
and Jordan proposes and then they say I
love you about 36 times and because this
is the finale let's go big I'm gonna
drink every time they say it I love you
and they're both so happy and it was
actually awesome to see even though we
pretty much knew this whole time she was
gonna fake Georgian and her exes Luke
and James both thought she was gonna
pick Jordan in fact you can has easy
online calm right now to check out those
interviews shameless plug but seriously
follow ET on Twitter and on Facebook and
subscribe to our YouTube videos you can
also follow me on Twitter regulars
especially I'm not sure it updates and
of course we must address the after the
final rose live event I don't know why I
started talking like this probably
because I drank so much so after the
final rose bravi was there I think is
there anything that's more clear as to
why one love was stronger than the one
love we had is for closure purposes yeah
and then Jordan came out and we
addressed everything potentially awkward
between Jordan and Jojo they talked
about tabloid rumors the rumors they've
been terrible and of course the Rogers
rift and they didn't really answer any
of Chris Harrison's questions any
conversations we have about that moving
forward are with us and about us this
moment in particular pretty awkward and
hopefully Erin can make it to the
wedding but in the end these two
honestly seems pretty happy they said
that despite everything that's happened
they did not even come close to breaking
up during these past couple months so
congratulations
Jourdan and Jojo a final finishing the
glass off cheers to you
I drink that's so fast mom I'm sorry
I don't know what happened to me either
guys the Bachelorette might be over but
bachelor in paradise begins tomorrow
night so please subscribe to e t--'s
youtube channel to get the latest roses
and or jose situations and thank you so
much for watching
all Bachelorette season